the holidays are very busy not just for
us humans we are going to get stressed
out you know it can be stressful for our
pets as well and joining us this morning
pet trend expert charlotte reed to talk
about the stress for our pets charlotte
you know when our houses are full of our
family members we're cooking we're
moving around there's kids running
around
uh it can be really stressful for our
pets and it can really be a big stress
on on everyone
absolutely can be a stress on our pets
as well as not only us but our guests so
it's really important to tell your
guests that you have pets and remind
them before they come in after they come
but you also have to be prepared and one
of the things i always say is this is a
great time to stock up on food and
litter and also canned food and treats
we've got various litter products here
food products and we've got uh some dog
treats uh it's a great idea to have some
extra treats on hand for the holiday
season and loving pets offers a
30 discount if you go to shopblp.com and
you put in
buzz 30. so that's great also the other
thing you have to think of what are the
dangers this holiday season and i have
to tell you the
classic symbol of the holidays is a
poinsettia it always gets a bad rap it
is toxic it causes gi problems and
that's about it you also have to
remember according to the aspca my
friend tina whistler there who's the
medical director chocolate is still the
big culprit the number one problem for
pets over the holiday season so watch
that chocolate also ornaments and lights
they're sparkly their shiny cats and
dogs love them including the christmas
tree how many people have heard about
cats climbing up the christmas tree and
knocking it over right at that key time
but then you're in those situations
where the phone rings or you get a text
message that ann m or your good friends
in town that you haven't seen in about
10 years and she wants to stop over and
of course there's dog and cat here all
over the floor so the great thing is now
we have so much smart technology whether
you need to clean the floor uh with an
eye mop or whether you want to vacuum
the floor with an eye vacuum all of that
is available and the greatest thing is
if you don't have it there are also
great savings this time of year so you
can keep your house clean throughout the
holiday season even when you have little
munchkins like these
you know charlotte obviously there's a
lot there's a lot there and there's a
lot that happens this holiday season but
if maybe you're a little pinched right
now a lot of us are struggling
financially right now and you've got
pets you got family coming over what are
just maybe some
the first things that people can do
right away to to make sure that they're
set up down the line just some some
quick things that they can do if they
can't do everything with the eye cleans
and all of this just some importance
you know one of the nice things to do is
very easily you could set up a little
room in your house maybe with the crate
hey you know what you can always go to
the um salvation army or you know one of
the goodwill centers and you can buy a
crate as low as five dollars have some
extra water bowls that way pets are
knocking it they're going to be away
from the holiday hubbub plants you
definitely want to put up high so
a cat or a dog can't get to it causing
very expensive vet bills but you know
there's also if you want you don't have
to buy expensive gifts you know that's
what it's not about like you said a lot
of people are having financial hard
times this time this time of year a
stocking with a bag of treats is just
great for a pet you know and of course
the traditional way just whip out your
vacuum have it you know in a closet or
nearby so that if people do call it the
last minute you can clean up or sweep up
or you know just take a a like a swiffer
type thing and just clean up the floor
really quickly spray a little air
freshener but the most important thing
is to remind everybody
not to open and close the windows
especially if you're having guests make
sure you have id you can go by id
at any pet store in one of the machines
uh it's pricing at about eight dollars
but that's very very key because people
get forgetful you know they open the
door they don't particularly close it
the dog and cat runs out but just take
care try to take it down a notch you all
get for dazzled you know you know not
you john because you're cool as a
cucumber
just dial it back a little bit that's
all you got to do and enjoy enjoy the
holidays with your pets and your family
and everyone charlotte have yourself a
good holiday season thank you very much
for those tips and we will see you next
time appreciate it